wenn es draußen weil es vom schnee ist
liegt der duft in der luft der jedem
wurde kann
wenn die weihnachtsfeierlichkeiten sally
bugs erlebt in der weihnachtszeit sagt
sellin citibank wird halo herzlich
willkommen so salis welt heute habe ich
ein kleines tannenbaum rezept für euch
und zwar habe ich hier tannenbäumchen
gebacken ohne spezielle backform ich
habe dafür nämlich backpapier verwendet
und das zu kegeln geformt also ein
richtig cooler typ eigentlich auch für
alle die es keine besondere backform
haben und innen drin steckten richtig
toller mann will biscuit außen herum
eine schokoladen hülle und die
tannenbäume die hab ich gemacht mit
kokosflocken die ich vorher grün
eingefärbt habe genau für weihnachten ja
was dann wollen wir auch schon in
türkischen ist es für den jahreswechsel
genau kann man nämlich auch ganz toll
machen und ich finde ich vor allem
deswegen schön weil es eben nicht so
eine cake pops masse ist die dann so
geformt wird sondern richtig lockerer
kuchen drunter steckt den man nach
belieben auch aromatisieren kann und ich
zeige euch jetzt zuerst einmal die
zutaten für den bhc ist wird das ist
nämlich das erste was ich machen werde
und da stehen schon mal die zutaten für
den teig brauche ich drei eiweiß eine
prise salz etwas vanille extrakt 3
eigelb 75 gramm zucker 70 gramm mehl und
100 gramm gemahlene mandeln für den
bizkit habe ich die eier bereits
getrennt und jetzt nehme ich so erst das
eiweiß und geht es in eine saubere und
fettfreie schüsse
da kommen etwas salz mit dazu und ich
kann den eischnee steif schlagen
jetzt gebe ich hier die hälfte vom
zucker mit dazu und lasst sie mischen
dann etwa eine minute weitere so sieht
der jetzt aus den einstellig ist kurz
zur seite und kann jetzt in einer
separaten schüssel das eigelb mit dem
restlichen zucker und dem mangel extrakt
vor etwa vier bis fünf minuten cremig
verrühren
jetzt die einst so schön cremig jetzt
kann ich den eischnee die mandeln und
das mehl vorsichtig unterheben
die masse will ich jetzt in einen einweg
spritzbeutel das dient lediglich der
einfache hilfe ihr könnt da aber auch
zum beispiel ganz gut ein gefrierbeutel
nehmen für die teilen baum form habe ich
jetzt hier backpapier bereits
zugeschnitten und auch geformt ich habe
jetzt kreise ausgeschnitten mit 16 cm
durchmesser und hab dann jeweils einen
schlitz bis zur mitte hinein geschnitten
und das ganze habe ich dann in sich
zusammen gedreht und hier oben mit
seiner edelstahl klammer fixiert jetzt
könnt ihr die in back feste tassen
reinsetzen ihr könnt aber auch eine
muffin form verwenden aber die sollte
auch tief genug sein damit die förmchen
so gerade wie möglich dann auch drin
stehen in ein paar tassen hat hierzu ein
bisschen mehr rein
denn ich glaube dass mehr verbrennt
jetzt auch nicht im backofen und dann
stehen die wirklich schön gerade drin
und da kann ich jetzt die biscuit masse
einfüllen
und so kommen die förmchen jetzt in den
vorgeheizten backofen bei 170 grad ober
unterhitze etwa 12 bis 15 minuten
die tannenbäume sind jetzt gebacken und
komplett abgekühlt und jetzt entferne
ich die klammer und auch das backpapier
und das übrige mail habe ich zusammen
geschuldet ist kann ich nämlich weiter
verwenden
jetzt seht ihr dass die tannenbäume
nicht ganz gerade stehen daher muss ich
jetzt unten den boden gerade
wegschneiden
di resta könnte übrigens vernaschen oder
einfach zu cake pops oder eine
geschichte weiter verarbeiten hier vorne
habe ich jetzt schon mal die zutaten mit
denen ich weitermache ich habe jetzt
hier 200 gramm weiße kuvertüre bereits
geschmolzen
ich habe ich 200 gramm kokosflocken und
etwas grüne lebensmittel verpasste jetzt
nämlich die kokosraspeln ich brauche
wahrscheinlich gar nicht alle daher
nehme ich jetzt erstmal nur einen teil
es sind weniger als laie wird da kommt
die grüne lebensmittel verpasste mit
rein und dann wird es schön vermixt
dadurch werden die kokosraspeln ein
bisschen feine wenig einen mixer habt
können dass sie auch so grob lassen und
einfach mit den händen mit der farbe
vermischen
so sehen die kurve flocken jetzt aus den
teilen durch übrigens sparen wenn ihr
zum beispiel pistazien nimmt und die
einfach mal und die tannenbäume damit
verziert aber ich glaube da wird mich
der murat umbringen es sind teuer
daher nehmen wir lieber die koppers
rausflogen jetzt nehme ich einen
tannenbaum und stecke ich hier zwei
stück spitze ein
das macht mir das arbeiten ein bisschen
einfacher jetzt kann ich den mit
kuvertüre bestreichen und dann mit den
kokosraspeln bestreuen
jetzt ist der letzte termin warum auch
fertig und wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr
jetzt opladen nehmen die hier sind jetzt
richtig schön weihnachtlich bedruckt und
dann nehmt ihr einfach ein bisschen
schokolade und klicks auf essen
ein kleiner tipp in meiner küche und
dann nehme ich die tannenbäume und klebt
die hier drauf so trocknet zum einen der
bizkit nicht aus und ich habe eine
schöne glatte unterlage
die tannenbäume hatte ich jetzt für eine
halbe stunde im kühlschrank die sind
jetzt auch schon fest man kann sie jetzt
auch hochnehmen und jetzt mache ich noch
einen bruder zuckerguss damit einfach so
aussieht als war steht drauf dann kann
es aber auch schon so lassen also ich
find sie so schon richtig schön
jetzt habe ich hier ein bisschen puder
dritter etwa 40 gramm
da kommt nun spritzer zitrone rein dann
zu einem dicken kuss verrühren und dann
könnt ihr den guss über die spitze
laufen lassen und gerne auch noch ein
bisschen streu kugeln und strecker
verwenden
so sehen die tannen wollen wir jetzt aus
die hinten habe ich so gelassen also
finde ich ganz edel und hier vorne habe
ich noch ein bisschen zucker schrift
verwendet und keine kugeln aufgespritzt
die sind auch nötig samira hat schon
probiert sie war sehr begeistert welchen
möchtest du gerne probieren
ich will ja einen verzierten wie den
kleinen hofladen ja so sieht auch aus
fleisch komme hier richtig cool von
unten hier mit weihnachten ja so
problems war ja die oblaten sind sehr
praktisch weil es eben nicht austrocknet
und die hand bleibt sauber also ich
deswegen jetzt zeig doch mal dubai hält
schon immer für dich zeig doch mal den
zuschauern und ok schmeckt jetzt richtig
nach schokolade nach mandeln und schön
locker oder unten herum komme auch
richtig cool essen finde ich auch ganz
aus der hand essen und finde ich gerade
für so einen schönen nachmittag zum
kaffee und kuchen eigentlich ganz hübsch
und vor allem können kinder mit
dekorieren es ist super einfach
hergestellt ohne besonderes werkzeug und
falls sie jetzt auch lust darauf
bekommen habt dann schaut doch mal auf
meinem blog auf facebook day vorbei da
steht noch mal alles ganz genau ich
wünsche euch ganz viel spaß beim
nachmachen und noch eine wundervolle
zeit wir sehen uns beim nächsten mal
wieder die sonne ganz schön mächtig mehr
wegen der schokolade ja ich möchte euch
auch über einen einstieg und irgendwie
doch noch makronen kann es sei halt halt
eine richtig locker aber ich würde keine
perlen nehmen ganz ehrlich ja ja die
zuckerstoffe den ball schön weich und
ich hatte nämlich vorhin auch schon eine
perle probiert und manche sind halt hart
bei dem ich hatte die waren eigentlich
ganz gut aber ja die da oben sind mittel
hat aber das macht also bis zum nächsten
mal